I'm Jodie Foster and I'm doing a wired
autocomplete interview okay we ready
[Music]
how old was Jodie Foster green taxi
driver I was 12 years old when I made
taxi driver
it was a summer it was hot and it was a
terrible terrible neighborhoods in New
York and I had to wear hot pants and a
halter top and platform shoes which made
me really unhappy I was a kid who liked
to wear knee socks but I knew I was
doing something great so that felt good
how does Jodie Foster speak in French
how do I do it I open up my mouth and
then it comes out I went to a French
school from the time that I was nine and
I was fluent by the time I was you know
10 1/2 or 11 years old and I spent quite
a bit of time in France so it's normal
that I speak French
perfectly bilingually two very young
children in problem vegimals new miss
you knocked about yeah everything's
going well today I have a problem with
my knee but otherwise I'm feeling good
third question how many Oscars does
Jodie Foster I love it I do I do to
Oscars that I actually own but I've been
nominated four times here we go
how does Jodie Foster stay in shape I
really love to ski so I can't ski all
year so I go to the gym that's what I do
does Jodie Foster have children yes I
have two sons Charlie and kit does Jodie
Foster have an accent do you think I
have an accent I have a little
California accent and then occasionally
it kind of goes into this sort of nasal
Connecticut accent because I lived in
both places does charity foster have
siblings yes I have three brothers and
sisters Constance Lucinda and Lucius
also known as Connie Cindy and Buddy
does charity foster give to charity yes
I do does Cherry does Jodie Foster vegan
oh that's great
I really don't vegan sadly occasionally
I'll go to a vegan restaurant but then
sometimes we're known to go to another
restaurant afterwards in order meet
sister Lee it isn't good it's Jody
foster a genius I don't think so
his Jodie Foster married to Mel Gibson
sadly I'm married to alexandra hedison
his charity foster in Lord of the Rings
dammit you caught me I wish it was in
Lord of the Rings nothing would have
made me happier than my favorite part of
lure the Rings was to cate blanchett of
course I would want to play Caitlin's
part in Lord of the Rings who else I
mean I mean I want the ears
it was the ears that was the key thing
did Jodie Foster ever play in Bonanza
yes I was on an episode of bonanza and
many many of those kind of Western funny
TV shows in the late sixties and early
seventies did Jodie Foster sing my name
is Tallulah what a good question uh no
they they dubbed my singing voice as
they did all of the children who sang in
Bugsy Malone sadly because I actually
was a singer at the time what does Jodie
Foster's Instagram guess what I don't
have an Instagram or Facebook or Twitter
or any of that I am actually thank God
old enough to not have to what is Jodie
Foster's IQ oh my god I have no idea
what my IQ is do people still do that I
don't not sure they do what is Jodie
Foster known for I used to be known for
you know making really good vinaigrette
not quite sure why that popped up on my
attributes but that seemed to me
something people cared about
what's your secret mustard is my secret
what did Jerry foster study at Yale
I study lots of things but I was a
literature major and my concentration
was African American literature and
African literature what is Jodie
Foster's real name my real name is
Alesia Christian Foster when I was
little my mom was proud while I was
really little I was in my mother's
stomach I was pregnant my brothers
sisters named me Jody and then she had
me she I don't know what happened she
was in the hospital and she changed the
name to a family name and no one
accepted it so I was called Jody for the
rest of my life but on all of my birth
certificates it says the Lycia Christian
foster what is Jerry foster doing right
now Jodie Foster is busy doing a junket
which is lots of interviews and press
for her new movie Hotel Artemis oh I
wish
to the third person ever thought what is
jodie foster's birthday I was born
November 19th 1962
I am Scorpio and there's lots of cool
people that were born in the same day as
me meg Ryan Ted Turner Raquel Welch
Indira Gandhi I think that was Jodie
Foster these are questions about the
past West charity foster on Gunsmoke yes
I was on Gunsmoke a number of times one
of the times I wore a wig because they
wanted me to look different was charity
Foster in Bad News Bears no I was not in
bad news bears that was Tatum O'Neal
wait what are you guys thinking West
charity foster on the Doris Day show yes
Jodie Foster was on the Doris Day show
yes I was that was a long time ago well
charity foster in Seinfeld no I was
never inside filled wish I was it's an
honor and a privilege to be googled
really is I guess I am not sure what why
but it is thank you so much for thinking
of me I love it that there are questions
about crazy bad television shows from
the late 60s and 70s